the value of y is always 3 more than
twice
x so we can say that y
is equal to
3 more
than twice x so 3 more than twice x so
it is 3 plus 2x is another way of saying
this first sentence so is y a function
of x so whenever you're asked whether
something is a function of something
else you're really just saying look for
any input x does it map to exactly one y
so if we say y is a function of x in
order for this to be a function for any
x that you input into this function you
must get exactly you must get exactly
one y so if you input an x you must get
exactly one
y value if you got two values then it's
no longer a function for any input you
get exactly one y you could have two
inputs that get to the same y but you
can't have one input that results in two
different outputs you don't know what
the function is valued at at that input
now here it looks pretty clear that for
any input you get exactly one output any
input uniquely determines which y it's
not like if you put an x in here you're
not sure what y is going to be you know
what y is going to be if x is 0 y is 3
if x is 1
y is 5. and so this is definitely a
function of x y is definitely a function
of x